I of course made it into my 30s with no
tattoos and there was a thought of keep
your body the way it is
you don't put a bumper sticker on a
Cadillac this body is a Cadillac don't
[ __ ] it up I've loved American
traditional tattoos for a long time I
feel like everyone was getting American
traditional tattoos like in the mid
thousands was like the hipster birth
coming out of Seattle and I always liked
those tattoos but I wanted to make sure
that this wasn't like some trend that I
was in two years gonna be like no I'm
into this now and with me at last that I
always loved the tattoos it never
shifted and so when I started I wanted
to keep it all American traditional I
[Music]
got my first tattoo about a year and a
half ago
Ryan Lewis was going to get a tattoo and
he was like just do it and I had held
out my entire life and then finally I
was like okay I'll get this clover on my
finger I'm Irish clover finger tat went
there and the clovers definitely not
centered whatsoever and that lasted me
like a couple months but the next two
opened up the floodgates
I got my daughter's name here I've got
this other woman smoking a cigarette
here that was just the start I think I
got probably like 15 tattoos that to her
every day I would wake up me like I'm
going to get a tattoo I will come back
with like three my most recent tattoo is
this Helen tattoo which is my grandma
she was in my music video glorious and
in the music video I took her on kind of
a bucket list run and we went to the
tattoo parlor together she picked out
the font and I got it tatted this is a
funny story because my wife is gonna
watch this and [ __ ] hate me it's like
you're getting all these tattoos that
why won't you get my name tattooed on
your body and I'm like that's the
[ __ ] curse you do not get your
significant others name tattooed on your
body do you want us to get a divorce so
I got mama a flower and she is my baby's
mama but it's also from my mama and I
tried to be like look it's for both you
guys and I think that just pissed her
off even more
my friend Noah passed away a couple
years ago at this point you know one of
my best friends growing up amazing
painter amazing community activist
visionary brilliant minds so I got this
in memory of him and you know I see it
all the time he was such a free artist
you know that's the way that I want to
approach the art that I make and this
reminds me of Noah who he was who he
still is
this one is one of my favorite tattoos
this is 2013 cherry this is a street in
Seattle but it's my fellowship hall for
my recovery this is my home this is
where I got sober what keeps me sober
this is big for me the only thing that
was really painful was this I have a
leopard which if I was in shape I would
show the [ __ ] out of it but I've been
eating bro a lot of my tattoos I get and
then I apply meaning to them after to me
this is like the whole play with death
don't do drugs but when I got at that
and I was just like that [ __ ] looks hard
once you start regretting anything in
life is just like Pandora's box of
regret that's why you just keep getting
tattoos though like I don't ever think
about the clover that I used to obsess
about everything's fine everything was
placed
Tommy forever chalk it up enjoy it and
get some more
you